madame la ministre lors de sa conférence
de presse le 25 avril dernier le
président de la république a lancé une
idée novatrice en annonçant la création
dans chaque canton d'une maison france
service où seraient regroupés les
services de l'état et tous les tous les
opérateurs en s'inspirant du modèle
canadien
quelle ne fut pas mon étonnement
s'inspirer du modèle canadien alors
qu'en france
bon nombre d'élus locaux les ont mises
en place depuis de si nombreuses années
en effet depuis la loi du 12 avril 2000
relative aux droits des citoyens avec
les administrations
ces maisons france service porte déjà un
nom elle s'appelle maison de services au
public m et ça paie bien avant certaines
exister en tant que relais de services
publics
aujourd'hui elles sont majoritairement
portés par les collectivités mais
également par la poste
pour être labellisée je me permets de
rappeler que les maisons de services
doivent contractualiser avec au moins
deux opérateurs dans le domaine social
et dans le domaine de l'emploi avec une
ouverture au public au moins 24 heures
par semaine et la mise à disposition de
locaux et de moyens informatiques
je veux bien saluer l'idée affichée de
proximité en revanche je m'interroge
quand à l'intérêt de proposer une maison
france service dans chaque canton
alors que certains sont parfois plus
grand que les communautés de communes
avons nous la mémoire si courte que nous
en avons oublié que la première de
toutes les maisons communes celles qui
appartient à toutes et à tous ce qui est
connu et reconnu s'appelle la mairie
très très longtemps les services publics
dont nous parlons tenait des permanences
petit à petit elles se sont raréfiés
jusqu'à disparaître
alors oui à la proximité oui à
l'accompagnement de nos concitoyens mais
donnons à des annonces qui masque la
réalité des actions déjà porté et
développé par les élus locaux
madame la ministre mais question sont
les suivantes quelle est la plus value
de ces maisons france services qui les
portera qu'elle soutient envisagez-vous
d'apporter aux maisons de services au
public déjà existante est porté par
l'essentiel par les collectivités
merci
si pour vous répondre la parole et à
madame jacqueline gourault ministre de
la cohésion des territoires des
relations act et que les 18 et la parole
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice marie pia affichée
je suis ravi de répondre à la première
question que vous posez en voisine si je
puis dire madame la sénatrice
je vais répondre à vos questions pour
vous dire que dans un souci de plus
grande proximité encore nous avons la
volonté du président de la république
annonce est effectivement dans le
prolongement des actuels maison de
services au public et bien la création
de france service bien sûr le premier
ministre a lui aussi annoncé la création
de cinq cents nouvelles maisons de
service public
je dirais elles seront installées là où
il y a des besoins c'est à dire là où
elle n'existe pas encore et bien
évidemment ce sera fait comme par le
passé
en collaboration avec l'opérateur la
poste qui est à nos côtés pour ses 500
nouveaux elle nouvelle maison et puis
également avec les collectivités
territoriales qui portent actuellement
le plus grand nombre de maisons de
services au public qui sont au titre au
nombre pardon 2340 dans le cher par
exemple il y a quatorze maisons de
services au public dont 10 portés par
des collectivités et 4 par la poste
2e 2e comment dire objectif au delà de
la plus grande proximité c'est de
remplir aussi de nouveaux services vous
avez dit il ya un minimum on va
augmenter le minimum parce que il y à
des maisons de services publics qui sont
très inégales il y en a qui apporte
beaucoup de services dont beaucoup moins
donc on veut à ce panier de services de
qualité pour que quel que soit le lieu
où se trouve la maison de service public
eh bien les gens aient la même réponse
enfin il y a les financements aussi
qu'il ne faut pas oublier il y a les
financements comme aujourd'hui
le gouvernement financera annuellement
sur une base forfaitaire de 30 mille
euros
pour conclure pour france service il y à
la participation également de la banque
des territoires et la formation de ceux
qui animent les maisons france service
par le fn
le cnfpt mai